well caravan from Central America is
walking through Mexico tonight they're
seeking to be let into this country
they're demanding and actually the
president says he dislikes that idea so
of course he's being called a white
supremacist my good army listen I mean
listen to that phrasing that this is an
army it speaks to an invasion of sure
brown people right front from central
and this is the implication there Easter
wouldn't be Easter without a little
brown scare right after his Happy Easter
tweet Donald Trump went right after
immigrants the first guy by the way was
Jim sciutto who works at CNN who was a
political appointee for Barack Obama now
pretending to be a journalist it's too
much mark Stein joins us tonight so mark
I guess the point that the left is
making right now is that we have no
right under any circumstances to deny
people entry when they come here period
doesn't matter who they are where
they're from what skills they have it
doesn't matter we have to let them in is
that the position yeah basically and
kind of what's whacky about this to me
Tucker as I understand it basically half
the illegal immigrant population
including these 1,100 people or whatever
it will be up to by the time they
actually hit the Rio Grande about half
the illegals in this country came here
since 9/11 in other words they broke
into a country that's supposedly on
orange alert we're told we're on our
orange alert if law-abiding persons go
to an American Airport they're parked
had all the time be advised the security
coding for today is such-and-such and
yet at the same time 1,100 people have
announced they're just going to walk
into the country and the United States
government throws up its hands and says
there's nothing we can do to shut them
by Mac that's what that what the hell is
a point of orange alert why are 300
million law-abiding Americans shuffling
shoeless through their airports like a
bunch of Oh like a bovine hard if
anybody if any of the six and a half
billion people who aren't American
around the planet can just walk across
the Rio Grande or take a flat flat
bottom
and walk into the country what's the
point of orange alert what's the point
of a government actually because the
point is that we're that we're the
problem is one of our guests earlier
told us is Jim sciutto or whatever his
name is on CNN told us we're the problem
actually these are the virtuous ones
trying to get in were the impediment to
their progress
shut up America and obey and you know he
probably doesn't know it there was a
French novel published 45 years ago by
Jean raspail the camp of the saints a
lot of people on the Left don't like it
but it actually predicted what's
happening before our eyes a bunch of
people got in a ship at India and sailed
for the South of France in this novel
and all the media commented like the CNN
guy you just quoted what's the big deal
about this we are the ones we are the
sinful ones we are the ones who have the
stain of all the wicked isms on our past
imperialism colonialism racism these
people are the virtuous ones let them in
and they will redeem us do you ever get
the impression you've been softened up
for this exact moment that people have
been telling you to shut up and obey and
that you have no moral standard and
you're not allowed to give your opinion
basically so we get to the moment where
you can just be told to step aside and
let people come in in your place I think
that's I think that's largely what it is
in fact and that's why I always pay
great attention to the left's assault on
language someone just said oh you know
those of us who oppose this
anti-immigrant actually know I'm an I'm
an immigrant it's a rather boring thing
to be because it involves going to
government offices and filling in
paperwork but the left has appropriated
that term so it now effectively means an
army of people who don't bother with
paperwork who simply as your first guest
said simply from being in poor
impoverished countries whose resources
the United States has pillaged
supposedly they have the virtuous right
to just walk in exactly to the country
so why should we care that a statute of
President William McKinley
a victim of gun violence by the way is
about to be torn down in Northern
California it feels like one of those
things that's worth paying attention to
why is it well I think it's worth paying
attention to because it shows that when
you hand the left of victory they move
on to the next thing rich Lowry the
editor of National Review said on Fox
News last year he said he didn't feel
terribly excited about defending robert
e lee and jefferson davis but you can
bet your bottom dollar that if they come
after Washington and Lincoln he'll be
right there defending those guys well
they're now actually tearing down
statues of American presidents of a guy
who took a bullet for his country you
once you give them that once you hand
them the first victory they simply move
on to the next ones and you know and you
know what's interesting to me tucker
obama when he was talking about what he
looked for in his judges said the
quality of empathy empathy requires us
to be able to understand human beings in
the age in which they live you're not
tearing down a statue of mckinley you're
tearing down the state you're tearing
down the representation of all the
americans who voted for him agreed with
him supported him you in fact disowning
your own history and saying i'm just
gonna live in a hyper present-tense
disconnected from my past that is exact
and i knew you could explain it better
than anyone I've ever met and that is
exactly right that's exactly bothered me
about it thank you for articulating that
appreciate it Thanks